one day you wake up and realize you're
not sure who the good guys are anymore
you're a federal agent involved in a
secret fbi program off the books what
kind of bad stuff do you do breaking and
entering
physical coercion
you name it i've probably done it
murder not on my menu
grandpa
gabe i've been thinking maybe it's time
i hang it up
no
travis i don't know
i know i wasn't a great father but i'd
like to be the best grandfather i can be
natalie doesn't need a fixer like you
i've been writing about the story for
over a year
the united states government is killing
innocent civilians under the guise of
protecting democracy
under whose orders the director of the
fbi
how many words have to die for you to
stop looking the other way
you need to come plain gabe
you're confused about our relationship
you are my weapon you work for me
count me out you show me a little
gratitude if you want a normal life
my hand is now
where's my family
if i find out you had anything to do
with my granddaughter disappearing
you're gonna need more men
you'll be finished before the day is
over
everything i
did is for you
are you really gonna shoot me travis
yes i will
grandpa
are you a good guy
i wanna be
[Music]
you